Intro
The marketing for Star Wars: The Force Awakens
kept this movie’s biggest reveal a secret
right up until release, when fans learned
that Rey, the scavenger from the planet Jakku
was the next trilogy’s hero, to be trained
by Luke Skywalker himself.
With Rey’s parents noticeably absent in
the story, and after more than a few hints
were dropped that the girl was following in
Luke’s footsteps, a ton of fans walked out
of the theater assuming the same thing: that
Rey was really the daughter of Luke Skywalker
– a secret that would probably be revealed
over the course of the new trilogy.
We’ve run down the evidence and theories
in a previous docu video, but as more and
more fans have taken father-daughter relationship
to be an obvious one, we think it’s only
fair to remind everyone that it’s still
just a theory for now.
In fact, when you weigh all the evidence,
there’s just as much reason to believe she
CAN’T be a Skywalker in disguise.
We’ll let you decide for ourselves when
our latest docu video is over: Is Luke Skywalker
REALLY Rey’s Father?
The Evidence: Mystery Parents
The most obvious clues may not be the most
convincing, but they’re impossible to ignore.
When The Force Awakens begins, Rey is living
alone on a desert planet – not too different
from Luke Skywalker’s childhood – or his
father, Anakin’s.
Rey is obviously a fan of the Rebel Alliance,
too, decorating her scavenged home with a
Rebel pilot doll, and even wearing a Rebel
helmet for the fun of it.
But once she reveals her last memory of the
parents who left her behind, the big hints
start dropping, as a flashback shows Rey watching
as her parents fly off, leaving her behind
on a backwater planet, but promising to come
back for her one day.
The plot point makes it obvious that Rey’s
parents are important, since audiences wouldn’t
have even wondered if the film hadn’t made
it a mystery to begin with.
When her interrogation at the hands of Kylo
Ren reveal that she imagines an island in
the middle of a sea when in need of comfort,
the movie ending on that exact same island
– with Luke Skywalker on it – was all
the evidence needed that father and daughter
were destined to be reunited.
And Luke’s best pupil would be his own daughter.
More Than Just Force Powers
Skill in The Force being passed from parent
to child may be all the evidence some fans
needed, but it wasn’t just Rey’s Force
powers that seemed to imply she had Skywalker
blood in her veins.
Take your pick: there’s her knack for flying
spacecraft, rebuilding and maintaining the
most stubborn spaceships and tech, and even
an immediate affinity for a droid on a mission
all fit the bill of both Luke and Anakin.
Her power was enough to get the attention
of Kylo Ren, seeming to be an even more powerful
Force user.
And if you believe that BB-8’s arrival on
Jakku, or Rey being pulled into the war between
the Resistance and the First Order was total
coincidence, then it was just as random when
Anakin, then Luke, were plucked from the same
situation for similarly great things.
Luck, or the will of The Force – you decide.
The Force Vision
The most convincing bit of evidence comes
when Rey first crosses paths with Luke Skywalker’s
lightsaber – the one originally built and
used by his father, Anakin, before it was
cut from, and with, Luke’s hand (Empire).
For starters, the lightsaber actually calling
to Rey implies she’s no random Force user
– and her childhood screams at being abandoned
on Jakku being used to call her to the weapon
add even more importance to the mystery of
their identity.
When she actually takes hold of the saber,
she’s given visions of Luke and Anakin’s
fight, Kylo Ren’s betrayal of Luke Skywalker,
Luke leaving directions to his hiding place
in R2D2 – basically, a crash course in the
Skywalker family, and a sign of what comes
next.
But it’s the voices spliced into the vision
which also seem convincing: Yoda and Obi-Wan
Kenobi, the powerful Jedi who trained Anakin
and Luke are both heard calling to Rey, telling
her that, just as was the case with both Skywalkers,
she is taking her “first steps” into the
larger world of The Force, and the Light and
Dark Sides of it.
Why would simply touching a lightsaber trigger
such memories?
If they were those of the new user’s father
and grandfather, it would make plenty of sense
to even casual fans.
And if Luke really did leave Rey behind before
heading into exile, her not just finding him,
but bringing the Skywalker lightsaber he had
presumed lost forever would probably convince
him that there was no use fighting the will
of The Force: helping a new Skywalker finish
the battle he couldn’t.
The Problems
Again, it’s all just fan theories and speculation
for now.
Fans have assumed that Rey is Luke’s daughter
for a reason, and it’s mainly due to hints
and clues that the filmmakers have counted
on the audience catching.
It could be true, but when you start thinking
about the actual twist and logic, there seem
to be some real problems with the assumption.
Beginning with the biggest reason some doubt
the upcoming reveal of Rey Skywalker at all…
It’s Just Too Obvious
It seems pretty pointless to go the trouble
of keeping a heroine’s identity a mystery,
and draw extra attention to the audience not
knowing who her parents are… and leaving
only one real conclusion for every single
viewer to draw.
Not just the diehard, conspiracy-obsessed
Star Wars fanatics, but even casual moviegoers
who leave the theater assuming they are to
believe Luke is Rey’s father.
J.J. Abrams has a better track record of twists
when it comes to his other projects, and frankly,
the reveal would be obvious to the point of
being boring.
Luke Skywalker living out his father’s origin
story seemed poetic, but doing it a third
time is wearing out the poetry – especially
if the goal is moving the series in a fresh,
inspired direction.
The problem then, is the conundrum at the
heart of the Rey’s parents mystery.
If it is a mystery at all, then it can’t
be Luke.
Because if it’s Luke, the mystery was obvious
from the word go.
Somehow, we think people will actually be
surprised when the identities are revealed
in the future.
But that’s just our gut talking – there
are other reasons that are a bit harder to
argue.
She Wasn’t Hidden Safely
In Luke Skywalker’s case, Obi-Wan Kenobi
took Anakin’s son to a backwater world,
leaving him in the loving hands of Anakin’s
stepbrother and his wife.
Fans can argue that Kenobi’s move was an
idiotic one, leaving Darth Vader’s son with
his own family, and even keeping his last
name.
But had things gone to plan, Luke would have
lived quietly and safely on a moisture farm.
In The Force Awakens, Rey isn’t left with
family, or even an acquaintance likely to
keep her safe: she’s left with Unkar Platt,
a cruel, unfair, deceitful scrap trader.
But fine, it’s still in the middle of nowhere,
safe from prying eyes, right?
Wrong.
When BB-8 pops onto the First Order’s radar,
Platt tries to buy the droid from Rey.
But when she refuses, Platt reveals he’s
secretly communicating with First Order agents,
and sells Rey out in a heartbeat.
It’s easy to think of reasons why Luke Skywalker
would leave his daughter behind: out of fear
he would corrupt her, too, or that she would
be a target for Kylo Ren, as eventually does
happen in the movie.
But Luke leaving her behind with nothing,
in the hands of a corrupt, villainous alien
who wouldn’t hesitate to sell her out to
Kylo Ren’s allies?
It doesn’t make much sense.
Even the idea that Rey is a daughter of Leia
Skywalker doesn’t hold water, since Leia
says herself that if she had kept her son
close, she could have kept him from falling
to the Dark Side.
So why would she make the same mistake twice,
or let Luke make it himself?
There’s A Better Story To Tell
At this point, the best surprise would have
to be the biggest.
And with all the rumors spinning and theories
being built, the biggest surprise would probably
be if Rey’s true parents were… just some
random people.
Maybe a jedi, or another character or family
from the previous films, but definitely not
a Skywalker.
We would be just as happy as the fans to see
that twist played out with love and purpose,
but c’mon: the third time telling the same
story would be… well, less groundbreaking
than fans were told to expect.
And would the prophecy of the Chosen One bringing
balance to the The Force, an act completed
when Anakin and Luke both defeated the Dark
Side, be better, or worse, if it was just
continued for another chapter?
Anakin fell to the Dark, so Luke could save
him from it… and Rey could do the same over
again?
The more interesting answer is that fans haven’t
seen the ending to this story before: maybe
the beginning, and maybe even the middle,
but shrouded in mystery, they won’t see
the conclusion coming until it’s here.
Could Rey be a descendant of Obi-Wan Kenobi
instead, with Luke forced to train his friend’s
descendant, moving Luke completely into the
role of his former Master?
Maybe Rey was the daughter of another missing
Jedi, or even a Rebel hero too dangerous to
even name?
It’s the same idea as mentioned earlier:
if Rey’s identity or lineage is meant to
be a mystery, then we tend to think just a
single movie in, it still is.
If we’re wrong, and Rey really is Luke’s
daughter, then it’s not the twist, surprise,
mystery, or story that fans – or the filmmakers
– must have hoped for.
And we can’t help but think feel that Abrams
would have done a better job of hiding it
so close to the start.
Conclusion
So what do you think?
Has the mystery already been solved, or do
you think there’s a bigger surprise in store,
or something fans are missing on purpose?
Make sure you take a closer look at our previous
investigation into the top theories on Rey’s
identity, and let us know your own theories
and thoughts in the comments.
Remember to subscribe to our channel for more
videos like this one, as we keep doing our
best to solve the newest mysteries of the
Star Wars universe.